hello and welcome to the new world
review i'm grand line waifu and today
we're going to spend a lot of time
talking about a family i gloss over
every time they turn up there will be
spoilers
there will be dislike there will be like
there will be probably subscribing
but we all need to play our part here
i'm subscribed are you
see i have in my hand one shiny
subscription
would you like it it's right there below
the video a gift from me to you like
kurta eyes to a weird teenaged
girl let's get into this because there
were more than a few happenings now that
the numbness of last episode has been
conveyed
where have we started this episode with
kilwa and gone who have finally
finally managed to track down korapika
where is leorio
away from here because realistically he
can't handle this situation
it's interesting that a character was
developed who so specifically can't
handle most situations that have been
presented thus far
i really hope that that's something that
changes for him in the next couple of
arcs because otherwise he's just you
know there anyway
thinking about it his are the only goals
that relate at all to helping someone
everyone else is in it for themselves or
not sure what they're doing anyway
here's looking at you kilwa speaking of
killah he got very upset because
kurapika decided to handle his
situation the way he wants to handle it
given the interactions that follow
and the way that his family has been to
this point it totally makes sense that
he would feel a personal slight to his
abilities despite the fact that he's a
child
in the literal and maturity sense of the
word over the last
number of episodes we've seen kurapika
mature very quickly
while the two younger teens have become
stronger but no more mature
in fact maybe they're going backwards i
feel sometimes that they've just
gone backwards in fairness it's likely
kudarpica already had that level of
maturity to begin with given the you
know type of trauma that he's
experienced but it's never clearer than
in the way he tells them to stay away
for their own safety and they throw a
hissy fit about it despite knowing that
actually they really couldn't take on
any of the troop not at this point
they'll find a way in they'll
get into that mix those two always end
up where they shouldn't be and in fact
now they're very specifically located
where the rest of the troop converged so
maybe that's actually something that's
about to happen overall this episode was
designed to set up the basic regroup but
also to give two sets of characters
we've had little interaction with the
chance to
wave their zoldics around i have nothing
against
them maybe but crollo at this point is
more endearing to me than kilwa's family
purely because he's passionate though
up to now both parties have simply been
what i would describe as
mute shadowy monsters for many episodes
the zoldics have turned up because as
assassins people want other people dead
and that's their forte why the common
suited people throw extreme shade at
them for being able to get the job done
when they're all afraid i have
absolutely no idea there were a lot of
moments to do with suited individuals
that i didn't really
understand if i'm honest i'm talking
about you bean
you're wearing a standard suit do you
not realize that if you're wearing a
standard suit you are
not in fact well-suited to this
situation it was quite enjoyable seeing
bean realise that his 2 000 strong
backup was just gone
oh dear the amount of stress involved
for him
at that point was a stress i wanted
conveyed to everyone else
it wasn't things got worse anyway
meanwhile kurapika's behavior i was
interested in he noticed very clearly
that there were a lot of mafia-based
individuals who could not protect
themselves
he knew that troop members despite not
knowing that it was specifically crallow
were in the building and there was a
moment early on where he acknowledged
that fact and it looked like he was
about to walk away from the job
repeatedly
maybe he should have i don't understand
i suppose why he didn't
at this point the clustering of the
mafia extras and the blandness of their
outfits suggest they either won't
survive because they're too easy to kill
as shown by the puppetry techniques used
by so many of the troop or
that they will simply die because
they're not important enough
could archer knows he's the reason the
trooper there and yet he still stands by
neon
the amount of conflict in that decision
somewhat irked me but i'm hoping there's
a greater payoff later in terms of his
making a decision to leave the employer
of the mafia
now this combat silva and xeno
zeno zeno silva zeno zeno i
look names i mean silver's nice and easy
at least silver and xeno complain about
how the finickiness of the contract
means that it's not worth it so why take
it the last time they met chrollo he
wasn't as strong
i assume they've all been training and
growing stronger but whether that's
actually the case i'm not sure
there's something to be said for the nen
powers that appear in this episode and
that is
purely for me the more they resemble
powers that occur in dragon ball or
dragon ball z the less interested in
them i
am there are so many ways in which this
show is incredibly creative and
incredibly detailed in its use of those
abilities
for example the puppetry like the use of
puppetry the use of strings that
heal people or well tie people back
together but also
be puppets is incredible and i love that
that the two zoldics pull out purple
energy dragons and purple energy balls
feels like a bit of a cop-out i can see
that these characters are supposed to be
really significant and sure they look
cool but something about their portrayal
artistically makes them fade into the
background for me
crowl's ability is more interesting
absolutely and the fact that he needs to
meet conditions in order to steal
abilities is great he does something
similar to what we saw with kurapika and
it's great to see someone
who should be a master at their ability
feels like a bit of a letdown if we
don't know what those conditions
are or get exposed to them i'm hoping
next episode we do hear more about them
the holding of the book is an
interesting one and maybe the others
have been met so the only one
dying this day will be xeno since krolow
specifically mentioned his discomfort
with a two against one scenario i wonder
whether the book will return
he seems the type to pull out a book and
flick through a page as energy balls
hurtle towards him
let's see if that becomes a thing in
episode 53 episode 53 great balls
enlightening
well this was a fun cover-up wasn't it
kurtapika finished the auction and did
what he was supposed to do including
buying fake curta eyes and giving them
to a kid to fawn over this episode was
indescribably sad and so i won't try to
describe it kurapika not thinking to
check whether it was accurate decided to
just
take as given the notion that the troop
were dead something that kind of annoys
me with this series is the dependence on
phones
just as an aside i understand that that
is how information is moved around but
the fact that literally everything
happens through phone calls makes for
pretty boring
watching when entire episodes end up
being communicated that way perhaps it's
because we now live in the era of video
calls but it feels impersonal and sort
of
hand wavy on another note to reiterate
going back to
you know some of the point of this
entire series the zoldicks are in fact
serious zold dicks illumi killing the
ten dons at crollo's behest while
crollow tries to find a way to steal
magical nen powers from people who only
half want to actually do anything to
hurt him anyway because it's too much
effort to try to kill him just wait for
you know
the son to go do the job i just they're
all a pack of
really aren't they maybe that's what i
dislike about them they show no passion
no interest in actually doing anything
beyond their job for whatever pay it is
they get and in fact
they're not even they don't even want to
do their job like
that i just don't get it i don't like it
i don't like it at all i understand that
that is literally the point of an
assassin but it also feels
i don't know lazy they didn't even try
and while i didn't know that last
episode this hasn't softened my
disposition toward them they're really
annoying characters and i feel an almost
visceral disgust toward them i
understand that to some degree that's
exactly what i should feel and it should
humanize kilwa more as someone who isn't
that and doesn't have those qualities
but they sent a shockwave through a
building big enough to make people think
they'd done their job and moved on
and something about that insults me on a
base
level maybe i've been working too hard
and need to take a leaf out of their
very lazy self-serving self-aggrandizing
book
god i hate them they're not even they're
not even poor dead bean
i didn't hate bean he had a cute name
and no ability to think for himself
rip sean bean again the auction
proceeding and all their fortunes given
to them by neon
they all think it's over it's not
there's something we're missing
something the mafia are missing
someone knows all those fortunes enough
to send them upstairs to distort them
perhaps and someone to just copy
everything and who the hell is cortopi
who the hell is courtope and where did
he come from why have i not seen him
before
why do they keep introducing new
characters with really convenient powers
why didn't kurapika touch the damn eyes
he'd have known they were fakes he has
some in his own head
he didn't question whose eyes they might
have been i mean no that's weird
but i would have in this world
i'd have taken the eyes and found
somewhere respectful for them rather
than mafia lord
karabakh is broken because he didn't get
to kill the troop but they're dead
though
i understand the concept of vengeance
but can't he be happy they're dead
he gets to live out the rest of his life
now until hisoka gets in contact with
him
speaking of hisoka why didn't kurapika
think to look for that body or to
contact him
despite needing to see the bodies he
didn't consider that hisokas wasn't
there
ah distraction bringing leorio and
zephyr back into the picture was
designed i think to soften the blow of
the episode and give us some levity but
all it really did was succeed in making
the episode that much more heartbreaking
when kurapika got in contact with them
maybe that was the true intention here
we brought everyone together except
karapika who
had no other meaning to his life beyond
avenging his family what happens when
there is no further way to avenge
what happens now that he has nothing but
a hunter license and close ties to the
group who killed his village
he got what he wanted he's very much the
right hand of someone in the right
position but the things he sacrificed to
get there
maybe too much and why now i highly
doubt however that this will be the end
of it i doubt that it'll take more than
an episode for him to find out that
those red eyes of his can spark up again
and in fact
have a lot of work to do and i wonder
whether he'll kick himself or want to
kick kilwa's family when he finds out
that they had a leader
let him go and wandered into the night
feeling like heroes
given how i feel about them maybe he'll
feel the same how wide is the net he's
willing to cast of the individuals he
holds responsible for the death of the
curta
and if he does then where does kilwa sit
in that would he stand up for his family
or stand against them and where the hell
is piggy still flying in everyone else
managed to make it where's he maybe
we'll find out next time but for now
that's it from me if you enjoyed my
clear dislike of the zoldic family feel
free to click here here and here
maybe hit the subscribe button maybe
like or dislike things and hit a bell or
something and i will see
you next time